hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zur
15 ausgabe von wer wird millionär
hier ist euer gastgeber was die apple
hallo ich begrüße auch direkt unseren
heutigen gast konkreter ich denk mal
hier ich mag dich mal da irgendwo ne
ecke war bleibt einfach da ich möchte da
noch ein paar äpfel hierhin wieder drauf
weil es mir im studio ach so ja das
machen wir fotos nackig machen eine
quizshow okay so so so minecraft so ein
bisschen und einfach micro das kenn ich
ja youtube youtube kennt sie nicht
dann wird wieder hier bin ja das frage
ich mich auch wie ich hierhergekommen
bin aber ich gehe aber irgendwo auch ein
publikum glaube ich also ich bin zwei
mal hier bin ich ja gut das ist okay so
ungefähr durchklicken wir das abläuft
kann mit frage noreau 1 es geht um 50
diamanten also erst mal ich hab mich gar
nicht darauf vorbereitet
das ist schlecht werde ich gleich noch
auf listen wenn du brauchst
man kann also fragen wir bereits es geht
um 50 diamanten und die frage lautet wie
viele verlinkungen hass auf seinem kanal
b2c 3 oder d4 meinst du jetzt verlinkung
mit sich so kanal also in andere kanäle
oder jetzt so an die 3000 prozent ich da
bin ich mir hundertprozentig sicher drei
sagst du facebook twitter instagram und
das ist richtig
ja 50 diamanten das nicht mal sicher
nicht werdet ihr manche mehr geguckt
oder wer wird millionär
da ist ein dorfbewohner kennst du
günther jauch ich kenne nur teil auch
den canceln auch dass das kennst du noch
ja ich kenne auch wer wird millionär
aber da ist eigentlich erst frage
richtig beantwortet man noch 50
diamanten sicher nein sie sind nicht
sicher ja aber es gibt so sichere stufen
ist sehr gut hier dann 516.000 16.000
und drogen fand einfach eine million
gewonnen
diese verdammten akkurat fressenden
schweine enten ok weiter ich möchte ganz
schnell nur einer von dessen schwein den
amboss wie sie sind der 2 es geht um 100
diamanten und die fragen von f rio 66
wie heißt der minecraft charakter
steven steve c oder d typ a
natürlich wäre glaube ich ist richtig
will ich auch noch nicht einloggen
ich will nicht sicher was habe ich eine
spitze für jogger du hast einmal den
internet joker den fünf die fünfte count
den tiebreak und internetkontakt
internet drama kurz nach co natürlich
darf mit kurzen porno angucken oder
e-mail was oder wer das die lösung der
frage beiträgt also was weiß uschi szene
ja ich nehme es tief dann das ist
richtig machen wir weiter
frage nummer drei es geht um 200
diamanten und die frage lautet wer war
kein gründungsmitglied des megaprojekts
geschäftsfeld bellut places park of
phoenix oder d sub prime pack of phoenix
das ist richtig ich glaube die bildung
15 fragen
jetzt nehme ich meine hoffnungen machen
wir weiter mit fragen um eur 4 es geht
um 300 diamanten molly frage lautet wer
ist nicht von drogen slums parodiert
pommes hdb sulak clp ohne kat oder dekan
michael
alter das ist echt kacke programm sehr
wenig bis gar ich weiß was war nochmal
die antwortmöglichkeiten pommes hd sowie
kakao oder keinen mich also kein mich
ich weiß nur dass pommes hd ist
parodiert ich glaube es gibt auch noch
dumm gespielt oder enkel was also sieht
man auch zwar nicht dumm gespielt aber
den gibt's ja aber der wurde auch
parodiert kein mich würde ich sagen auch
ich will keinen joker verwenden aber
wenn ich rate dann habe ich dann direkt
verloren oder der täter also ich würde
auf jeden fall tendieren zu dieser suika
kita tack tack am echten so die tak und
lee parody pack also kein mich bin ich
mir eigentlich
ich habe ich mir dabei sicher bin bei
keinem michael das ist nicht also kein
mich um kommissar will ich einfach sagen
nicht nur noch zwei übrig ob man nochmal
die 2 lp oder katie und suri kag ich
sage einfach so wie kann das jetzt
einloggen
welch ein und das ist richtig schluss
verfahren läuft ja gut machen wir mal
wieder mit fragen um 5 es geht um 500
diamanten wenn du die richtig
beantwortet das hast du 500 diamanten
sicher wie viele kanäle hast du in
deiner abo box 18 98 dlv alter ich
dachte jetzt kontert 15 15 oder 20 aber
die liegen ja direkt beieinander wartet
darf ich mal ganz kurz aufzählen ob ich
die noch die lande auf die reihe kriegt
also da ist auf jeden fall drin mein
zweiter kanal erstmal konstanz da
steffen drin dann auf jeden fall die
beiden hd s tronic und komme dann du
nicht nein danke gaming-pc 5 habe ich
auf jeden fall auch noch drin also dass
jonathan tiere dann wieder weiß ich
nicht ob ich die noch drin hat dessen
freunde von mir die musik machen
aber weißt ich nicht ob ich die noch
drinnen habe ich glaube hier
weil ich das auch den habe ich auf jeden
fall noch drin um gespielt habe ich drin
luke habe ich noch drin hab ich damals
eigentlich den gleichen namen hatten und
jetzt
wobei tiempo arbeit den beiden kanälen
wir möchten die sich ja aber das sind
schon mal einen zweiten kanal steffen
dann die beiden hds das sind 4 gaming-pc
55 simon sechs der sieben new players 8
also entweder 8 9 oder 10 auf keinen
fall 11 8 9 oder 10
also jonathan toews ich bin ich mir sehr
sicher dass ich hier drin hab also neun
habe ich mein tier nehm drin oder nicht
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß echt nicht
ich weiß was habe ich noch mal für
jogger 50 5 die internet und telefon
aber das ist ja gerade die fünf die
eigentlich so mehr oder weniger letzten
50 prozentige chance 9 oder 10
ich glaub ich hab den noch drin weil der
glaube ich nicht also rechts am rand
steht der glaube ich nicht weil da
stehen ja nur fünf oder sechs oder so
brandt weiß nicht ob er das steht aber
ich glaub nicht und deswegen hab ich den
vergessen raus park wurde ich hab's
allgemein 18.10 sagst du glaub ich hab
jetzt kommt er wieder andere emotionen
2.0 er gut war bereit für fragen nummer
sechs bin ich bin ich bereit es geht um
1500 hast du sicher so und die frage
lautet welchen blog gibt es nicht im
creative inventar
aber den kohleblock b bedrock den
komment blog oder den eisblock a alter
ich habe gerade überhaupt keinen plan
was wo hat man petrov dadurch also
kohleblock aber 1000 prozentig das was
noch kohleblock den hat man auch auf
jeden fall drin alter command blog hat
man glaube ich nicht drin
ich glaube den hat man nicht drin
erwarten doch kurz überlegen
bei brad walker hat man den bedrock drin
bei mir geradezu die sache zwischen red
rock und hardrock und command blog also
ich würde ich glaub ich lag schon mal so
halb command block 1
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ich bin
das ist klar
also ich glaub command blog habe ich
dann noch nicht
ich weiß nicht ich bin echt nicht sicher
ich hab ich kein plan sei command blog
oder petrov alter du denken jetzt höre
ich dem komplett falschen kohleblock
gibt sogar eine wachmann command rock
oder bedrock boah ich bin mir echt nicht
hier
ich kann jetzt auch nicht in den
creative mode hier gucken weil ich bin
acht wir haben sich die angriffe gegeben
bisschen langweilig ich bin ich mir dass
mir noch kurz ein bisschen zeit
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ob command
lock oder netlock
ich glaube sogar mehr bedrock weil ich
sage kommando blog man blogs hast du ich
hab den da noch nie nie gesehen in
diesem redstone mio da bin ich
eigentlich relativ oft dann wenn ich
irgendetwas test oder so vor allem im
singleplayer dass ich sage mal es ist
richtig ich war bisher dreimal
ausschlussverfahren war richtig machen
wir einfach beim nächsten mal beim
nächsten lied joker musst du musst du
seid ihr jetzt schon okay frage moment
kommt man trotzdem drauf die frage kommt
von brain odin ort nähen und es geht bei
dem 2000 diamanten
wann hast du dein erstes video mit face
com hochgeladen
das entscheidungs video gemeint also ob
fan oder nicht
a beste entscheidung das audio am 12 dem
dritten b am 22
3c am zweiten dritten oder die am 29
nochmal die antwortmöglichkeiten
der artist alles dritter also zwölfter
22 starts weiter oder 29 hat man bitte
im chat die daten in zwölfter 2 euro
gewährte das erste richtige gameplay 12
8 so das erste gameplay mit facetime
oder nein
entscheidungs videos das doch mal über
ein video gemacht ob du fest kann man
sollte da nicht einfach das erste video
mit verkehr bekommen
ja aber ich habe ein video gemacht wo
ich mich zeige und einmaleins woher die
erste base camp habe und ich weiß nicht
welche zu haben willst ich glaube
überhaupt das erste zeige video
ich wusste den termin
ich wusste den ich habe mir den ich
gemerkt so wie wenn man mit einer
freundin zusammen kommen oder sogar von
benno möhlmann hast du dein erstes video
mit facebook land damit ist nicht das er
wird bestimmt zu schreiben
damit ist nicht das entscheidungs video
gemeint hier stimmt steht hier nicht
also das erste video was ich mit
facetime gemacht ich habe wow was sind
das für sachen ich weiß nicht mehr was
ich da gemacht habe in dem video we've
ace kameras internet joker schiesst
auskommen ja ich nehme internet yoga und
schneller
ach ich darf noch gucken hier hd+ nach
oder wäre ich dann nach guck ich weiß es
doch auch menschen liefert mich in skype
geld wird so also muss jetzt einfach mal
bitte die daten sagen 12 22 21 davor
gewesen sein
irgendein gefechtsköpfen drin ist ja
toll man mit dem radl
das so dass hier glaube dass es das
wetter vor hunger games
das auf privat gestellt nämlich nicht
wirklich an
ich sag mal was war noch mal die daten
12 22 zweiter oder 29
vielleicht 50 50
mama bitte 12 22 2 oder 29 zwölfter sein
darf ich auch in skype gucken wie in
skype gucken ich habe einen chat verlauf
mit einem und er hat mir da in die
geschrieben jahr hätten wir so schnell
weil ich einfach wir haben ich würde
sagen doch noch mal ganz kurz die daten
zwölfter 22 oder 29 zwölfter zweiter
reiter auf kleinsten 22 2 oder 29 22 12
22 29 was vom 10
ich weiß noch am ziel mehr als habe ich
mich zuerst gezeigt dass ich glaub nicht
dass am 12
das video der online kam das wäre eine
überlegung
hab gesagt ich glaube nicht dass wir
eine überlegung wert
das los entschied das also erst mit 29
ich würde grob sagen 22 willst du das
einloggen
soll ich denn sagen okay also auf jeden
fall nicht 29 grad in videos zum
beispiel in mein will
das ist vom 27 jahre sagt 22
richtig aber es musste dich jetzt eine
antwort drängen wäre geburt machen
einfach leichter wird fragen aber macht
es wird jetzt aber ist leichter mit
fragen um macht es geht um 4.000
diamanten und die frage lautet wer hat
nicht die 100.000 abonnenten erreicht
komme also zurzeit zu diesem zeit diesem
zeitpunkt jaguar bmw spiegelt alles ist
evonik oder de klaus borkes aber diesen
auch knapp davor glaube ich und dann
aber jetzt geht schnell ihr bei der
frage in dem rund 8000 diamanten frage
09 es geht um 8.000 jemanden und die
frage lautet wer ist die neueste person
im mega projekt a 6 lpg cartel media cdb
oder dlp baby und das ist auch richtig
es geht um 16.000 hier welcher reallife
youtuber macht ebenfalls minecraft let's
play hatte ja weiß ob das kommt
b mit respekt c oder d
der erste apple war ja das ist richtig
rasiert weiter geht's die langsamste
braucht hat das 30 minuten waren die a
10 minuten 1 30 ebenfalls ungefähr 30
sehr gut weiter machen wir weiter mit
fragen der u11 es geht um zwei übrig
dass die 16.000 sich 32.000 diamanten
geht's jetzt und die frage lautet wie
viele mitglieder hat pietsch mit 35 oder
36 also in dem in staffel 6 waren die
sechs leute das weiß ich noch also ich
würde mal sagen weg soll ich das
einloggen
das einloggen
das ist richtig ja wir sind in einem
trichter diamant und so was alles drin
ja da waren meine ganze ich habe mir
selber diamant regen machen wird er war
meine hände haben eine ganze zeit lang
titel drin mit dem namen was die sg die
haben
die hat mein bauteam hier versteckt
irgendwann brauchen fans läuft in studio
reindrücken aussehen auf den trichter
sehen die ganzen zettel mit dem namen
bastis game lachen mich aus
machen wir heute mit frage nummer 12 die
freikommen von nico 1 6 6 7 6 8
und es geht um 64.000 diamanten welche
augenfarbe haben silberfische im default
texture pack las vegas oder de sie haben
augen also die haben augen ausrufzeichen
fragezeichen
die haben wir hoffen dass ich war nicht
also silberfische die haben augen
also warum ist eine frage die antwort
auf meine frage silberfische welche
augen fünften mal vor die möglichkeiten
blau grau schwarz oder nix
die augen ich glaube die haben sogar auf
also sie haben keine mono brauche also
aber wenn man doch immer an die antwort
nimmt
wir haben augen fragezeichen ausnutzen
ist es doch die antwort die haben keine
augen so einfach oder nochmal regal ist
nämlich ähnlich die haben augen setzt du
da nicht drei andere sachen gepackt also
blau auf gar keinen fall weil das nicht
zu grau passen würde
was noch grauen schwarz
es gibt kein schwarz und grau gibt es
noch was im boden im schwarz weiß grau
und grau das wird man keine augen sehen
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass das
ding augen hatte zu erlangen
das ist richtig
ja gut ich setze mich hin machen wir
weiter mit frage nummer 13 es geht um
125.000 diamanten die frage von unix hd
und sie lautet wie viele blöcke gibt es
in minecraft 82 bei 125 c 158 oder wild
204 also das erste war die massen 80
oder so das auf gar keinen fall
boah das ist so eine rate frage da kann
man nicht so warte ich guck mal ganz
kurz immer ein inventar das sind 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 9 eine breite bei der ersten
seite geht es locker schon mal 56 runter
das heißt 96 sind schirme uns auf jeden
fall auch mehr als was war das immer die
anderen drei zahlen
125 150 oder 200 4 monat vier sollte ich
weiß nicht ob ich das ein soll das oder
ich nehme ja toll da kommen dann die
letzten beiden zahlen raus beim 55
das dann auch kacke ich nehme fünf titel
und es bleiben übrig öl 158 und 82 die
158 wo gott ich hätte euch 204 genommen
hätte locker genommen dass es war
richtig und ist mit wie viel kohle habe
ich als 125.000 alter bin ich da schon
mal in die hall of fame so drin du bist
auch mit 0 in der hall of fame der
eingetragen wurde f bin ich aber nicht
weiter machen wir weiter mit frage
nummer 14 es geht um 250.000 diamanten
und die frage lautet wie heißt lang boy
mit vollem namen
er ist lang boys ist ein mitarbeiter von
mojang dankbar
das ist der typ ich weiß dass man
gesehen dass der zeigt sich nicht auch
auf der mine konnten bei der aufnahme
von der mine kann hat er immer sein
gesicht achte hd ist markus oder matisse
oder matisse gramm dpd lose die normale
drohnen c
martin und mark oder tipps verrät ich
weiß dass bergkristall wurden hast du
auf jeden mark und ich weiß nicht wie
ihr nachname aber auf jeden fall war
richtlinien
das ist richtig aber welt bei twitter
stand irgendwie mal so da ich folglich
folgten und chip und chap hat irgendwie
diese markus verlinkt da dachte ich erst
mal in lodz und dann als demi markus
working on blablabla ja wieviel modding
der meint markus working und blabla und
ich so hell wie model arbeitet noch
daran dass ich da drauf gegangen ist
also wenn dieser dankbar dass ich diesen
komischen skin damit diesem superman
oder diesem roten weil gelben der beste
weg ist weg ich laufe nicht weg ich bin
die kamera ich stehe hier machte
lass mein pferd in ruhe mit meinem pferd
und wenn doch wird der millionenfrage
beenden weitermachen ach so ja ja okay
ich vor gott wenn ich jetzt mache ich
noch ein joker
du hast noch einen joker gelb da kann
ich den anrufen genau und er kann auch
nachgucken
der killer warum wir weiter wird fragen
euro 15
die frage kommen von lowe's zucker 1 und
sie laut dass in welchem stockholmer
stadtteil wohnt notch
punkt holen beese der x te normal oder
de ist der mann
ich nehm joker skype locker ok dann
einfach mal kurz ein katemann kannst du
jemanden holen
so jetzt hat kontrolle von drucker der
gast der letzten episode ist mit dabei
re wie eine windel wird die frage der
rewe ja okay also weißt du zufällig in
welchem stockholmer stadtteil notch
wohnt was er war die richtige wahl
wegstreichen stadtteil wohnt not revier
das ist die eine million frage darf ich
googeln klar ja dafür
er wohnt in lodz in stockholm
diese notieren also ich hab mein leben
ich habe seit der macht die ganze zeit
hier sagt markus perl sondern guckt noch
mal ganz kurz player wohnt jetzt geht
jetzt telefonbuch oder moment eigentlich
ziemlich einfach muss man auch wissen
dass der im stadtteil soll der mann
wohnt der mann moment soll er da mal hin
ziehen
ich habe eine million gibt ja das stimmt
das ist auch richtig so noch viele grüße
von simon bestellen
danke bestellbar schöne grüße zurück
hätten von simon und feiert das danke
sie mannigfaltig auch okay später machen
das server begreifen mitnehmen in make
up projekt oder die ganzen ja mann
kannst du nicht auch man schade ja die
erste group ist damit der erste neben
brocken vom nein ach du bist einfach ich
glaube bisher sechs oder so wer die
wenigsten punkte tiefer und wo ja
minecraft die sind beide von 8.500
runtergefallen
aber ich fand das jetzt ich fand zwar
relativ schwer zwischendurch aber ich
glaube ich habe einfach richtig gut
geraten sobald ich hab so ein gutes
ausschlussverfahren einfach angewandt es
war sehr gut bestehen wir sagen wir
wollen das schön gut
darf ich vor brocken fans stehen nein es
ist chronologisch geordnet das war's für
eine folge danke dass du mit dabei warst
ja keinen spaß und wir sehen uns dann
das nächste mal wieder und noch wunder
rief danke dass du mich gespielt das und
die fragen großteils gemacht hast und
generell landungen die eingesendet haben